- So when you were
a young deaf girl,
what kind of access
to information
and technology did you have?
- To be honest,
I was closed off.
I spent
my whole childhood lost.
I would be sitting
next to my parents
as they watched a movie or TV.
They'd be laughing at the TV
and I would just be looking
trying to guess
what was going on,
and if I needed
to call my parents,
I would have to walk up
to a stranger,
tap them on the shoulder
and hand them a note saying,
"Would you mind calling
my mother
and having her
pick me up here."
Then I'd just have to stand
next to this weird stranger
and watch them blabber
on the phone
and then look at me like,
"Okay, your mom's on her way."
- Yeah, well, I mean,
it's a good thing
they weren't calling, like,
their other kidnapper buddy.
Like,
"Hey, I got this hot deaf girl.
Bring the van."
- Ha, ha.
You know, you get used to it.
You just kind of accept
that that's your lot in life.
"I guess I'll just have limited
access to communication."
- So did the Internet remove
some of those limitations?
- Absolutely.
The Internet and technology
gave me freedom.
I feel more intelligent,
more confident,
and I feel better about myself.
- And when you were young
and you wanted to,
like, call a friend,
how would you do that?
- I would actually have to ask
my mom to call my friend's mom
and set up an appointment
for the two of us to hang out,
and then we'd drive 30 miles
or something
to go meet my friend.
- Right, so now
you can finally just call her.
- Right.
I could do that right now.
[line trilling]
Hi, I can't talk.
I'm on TV doing an interview
with Moshe.
Look, look, look,
here's my best friend.
- Hey, everyone!
[scattered laughter]
- So then I decided,
"You know what?
I'm going to get
a cochlear implant.
One of those robotic ears,
and that
really changed my life.
- You ever see those videos
of deaf people turning on
their cochlear implants
for the first time
and everybody gets
all emotional?
Like, I realize we never got
a chance to do that,
and I've always been
kind of disappointed.
Do you think we could try it?
- Okay...
- Okay, now fake turn it on.
Hey, Mom.
- Is that your voice?
- Mom, here's my voice.
[laughter]
[mouthing]
- Oh, my goodness.
[mimics crying]
- [mimics crying]
- Oh, I can't believe
that's your voice.
[laughter and applause]
- [mouthing]
- [mimics crying]
- I'm so happy.
[scattered laughter]
[violin screeching]
♪ ♪
- Thumbs down.
Sorry.
Yeah, look, I'm deaf
and it still sounds terrible.
You know,
I remember when I first got
a closed-captioning device,
like, a subtitle machine,
and I would put it on
and sit with you
and we would watch
"Sesame Street" together,
watching the subtitles.
I had captioning
and I could finally understand
what was going on.
I missed what was happening
when I was a kid,
but I didn't have to miss it
when you and your brother
were young.
- Well, thanks for coming, Mom.
I love you.
- I love you too.
- Now, uh, go.
Seriously, go.
Get out of my house.